today we're going to learn about how to
find the midpoint between
two points you've got you've got points
we're doing coordinate geometry
if you know where the points are they're
coordinates you can work out all kinds
of things what kinds of things do we
already know by the way
we already know how to find out how far
it is
between them which is the distance
formula now let's see how we go
um distance equals i'll start you off
there's a big square root sign okay but
what goes under the square
do you remember yeah
oh close okay there are x in there
okay good you could you could start with
x or y that's fine what do i do to this
thing
all right no wait there's something
missing i have to do something to this
square i square it right why is it
squared
do you remember where did it come from
it came from
pythagoras do you remember pythagoras so
that part was squared and then you told
me to add to what
y squared minus
two same thing but with one okay good
okay so you remember there was also
another way to write that uh we said
like these two things really right
that's kind of
uh i swapped them around this is this is
rise here
right y2 minus one it's a vertical thing
and this is wrong
okay so another kind of handy way that i
wrote it was
it's rise squared plus one square
okay now rise and run that should remind
you of the other thing that we've
learned to do
between two points if you know where two
points are you can work out what other
thing
so far not just distance but it starts
with a g
right gradient gradient
oh it's dying i need a new one okay
let's see if we can make it
um gradient gradient's about like how
steep is it
between things right um so gradient was
do you remember what the formula was a
fraction
what was what was the word good it's
rising right it's the same pieces
it's the same two pieces rise over
run okay so therefore if i substitute
for the x's and y's and stuff
you got this
okay so we did distance we did gradient
now if you've got two points we want to
work out what's halfway between them
okay
so we'll start with a simple example by
now hopefully you've had enough
time to draw that up let's put some
coordinates on these
that point a there it looks like about 1
1 to me let's just call it one one
okay now assuming like this is the uh
horizontal the x-axis here i've tried as
best as i can
to draw this interval ap parallel
right so what should we call it let's
see what coordinates does it look like
it might be
that's one i guess it'd be like two
three four five six
maybe six across now i have a question
for you
what will its y-coordinate be
it'll also be one why is that
that's right in fact anything along here
you can put it any like over here or all
the way over there
the y coordinate will always be one
because that's about how high
up or down you are okay great now
six oh actually let's change it to seven
just because um
it'll make our numbers a bit easier
you'll see
sorry forgive me now
we want to work out what's halfway
between these two so we can actually
plot this in it looks like it'll be
somewhere about here
i'm just estimating okay for now we're
just estimating okay but we're going to
work out exactly what it is in a second
okay now because it's the midpoint we
tend to um
load that down with a capital m not a
lowercase m because that was gradient
right
that's a lower end so here's my capital
m but
um there will be midpoints of all kinds
of different points i'm going to add on
a third point in a second right
so being that there will be lots of
other points there will be lots of other
midpoints
i want to say this is the midpoint
between
a and p so the way i indicate that is by
saying a
p in little letters subscript down the
bottom
okay so i read that as the midpoint
of ap that's when you put it all right
now we want to work out
where is this thing where is this now
you can already actually tell me
you can tell me what the y coordinate is
straight away right
it's still one just like p and just like
a
right because they're all on this line
okay so that's good
but the x-coordinate is a bit trickier
not that hard though can anyone tell me
could anyone see what they
like make a good guess as to what it
would be
yeah four four what do we think of four
yeah do we agree with four three point
five three point five
okay this is great that we're trying to
work out because we know we're all
roughly in the same area
we all know that two is too small and we
know six is
too big right now how do we work out
what it is how do you work out
what's halfway between two different
things okay
there is some division involved here's
what we're gonna do how did i get four
okay i think the way you get four is you
have seven
and then you add one right which is this
other distance over here
and then you divide by two you're taking
the average
right remember from statistics we looked
at the mean the average you add up all
the different things and then you divide
by however many
things there are so this is taking the
average now that 802
which sure enough is four okay now
there's another way you can check to
show
that four and not three and a half not
four and a half
he's right what'd that change the pay
and then it says yeah originally oh
sorry you're looking through
right gotcha um the way that we can know
is that the midpoint right what makes it
the midpoint is it's
halfway between the two right so
therefore this
distance and this distance
they ought to be the same right if we
got the midpoint
correct okay so how far is it from a to
the midpoint
right it's three units exactly right uh
it hasn't gone up or down at all
and it's gone from one to four sorry i
should take one
to four so that's that's three good
four to seven is also three so we've got
it
there you go perfect okay well done
right now above this we're going to add
another point
and this time we're going to add it
directly above
p okay so let's put it up here
so i'm going to call this one b and it's
going to have the coordinates
now i put it directly above like this
so therefore even without seeing
anything about scale and that kind of
thing you can tell me already what the x
coordinate is right
if it's directly above it'll also be
seven
good okay now just for the second
illustration i'm gonna make this five
okay now again let's work out the
midpoint i'm gonna mark it in
approximately like
that okay and because it's the midpoint
between
b and p i'm going to label it midpoint
of bp okay so now i want to work out
what are these coordinates okay what
these chords
now again you can still just read off
what's the x coordinate yeah
um seven comma three okay now you've
given me both
yeah now let's work out how we got this
the seven why is it seven
it's still on this same vertical line
okay everything on this vertical line
will have an x coordinate of seven okay
now how did we get three how did you get
three yeah because the middle
like if you have like five things the
middle one of those five things would be
three
okay all right okay so if you've got if
you've got five objects you're saying
like a b c d e
okay yeah so you're saying look the the
middle one is the third one
right okay this is interesting because
we have arrived at the right answer
but i wonder if anyone could see the
flaw with this way of arguing it you're
going to say something else or are you
going to talk about that
yeah go ahead it's five plus one divided
by two
five plus one
that's three okay now hold on we both
arrived at the same number
but i think this is a much better way to
go about it
than this okay let me try and explain to
you why
um what if i wanted again to what if i
want to take the midpoint between these
guys i'm not going to
okay but suppose i wanted to okay
uh what well you guys can actually see
what's the midpoint between them
it'll be seven four won't halfway
between these but
but the middle of five is still three
right
you know just like for a simple like
explaining that's true but the simple
example
breaks down when you look at another
thing right so that's why this one
doesn't break down though because we can
just change this number
if i change that to three then this
would be eight and you'd get four
okay so that's why i think this will be
a better approach
it's more versatile if you like okay now
just like before
you can see what's this distance versus
this distance
they're both they're both two right
so we've got the midpoint fantastic